brothers and sisters
i think now more than ever
critical thinking is something that we
have to if we haven't already developed
we have to develop it
i want to go off of the quran where god
almighty allah the creator is telling us
very important ayah that if a fascist an
evil doer a liar
someone untrustworthy comes to you with
some news you got to go check it up
you've got to go and verify it
in today's day and age with mainstream
media
we can understand we've seen patterns of
this over and over and if they've did
studies they've shown how much truth is
actually put out versus the falsehood
through mainstream media and they rated
it and an
overwhelming amount is just fake news
false information so we don't want to
get
overly emotionally invested if someone
is used to watching
fox news and now you're just you like
this anchor for instance
and you get really emotionally invested
in this person
someone gets emotionally invested in cnn
for example
someone gets emotionally invested in npr
this is all mainstream media
now you have to if you go down that
rabbit hole and many have and then they
bring to light
who's actually behind these few
corporations you got five six of them
that own the mainstream media big pharma
pays their bills drug companies spend
about five billion dollars a year on
advertising with these media outlets
only it's it's only been through
non-corporate
independent media outlets that these
stories are told at all
the corporate media doesn't care
about these stories because they either
share board members with these companies
or because
they want those companies to keep
throwing huge advertising dollars
their way they're always going to
express the ideological views of their
owners their
corporate owners fortunately an
increasing number of americans
are starting to wake up and realize that
the mainstream media
should not be trusted in recent years
we've seen the alternative media
experience
rapid growth mainstream media has been
losing credibility as
staggering rate and americans are
starting to look elsewhere for the truth
about what's really going on
and then i often make this example and
you can contrast it for instance let's
say of us
the believers and the one god the
believers in
the divine and his blueprint for life
the purpose of life that we have that
calls us
to everything good let's say we ran this
media
we'd want to eradicate poverty you have
like over
4 million plus people dying
yearly of of
lack of food we'd want to use that media
to push out and we highlight that to
motivate people to give and we
look to eradicate that right but now
when you have
other people controlling it according to
open secrets big pharma spent more than
58 million dollars on politicians in
2016 the most amount they've ever spent
on direct contributions
in the last quarter century why because
they
big drug companies want politicians to
do what they order them to do
and when it comes to lobbying few
industries spend more than big pharma
last year the industry spent
a staggering 244 million dollars
to influence our elected leaders in
washington dc
they have an agenda for instance the
former ceo
of fox roger alice when he was asked
there were certain facts
they were brought to his intention of
certain drugs
from the pharmaceutical company that
were actually
killing people bringing a lot of harm
vioxx for instance killed close to small
numbers like in
in a matter of so many years
they were pushing and fighting and what
not to keep vioxx for instance this is
one drug that killed so many people has
proven to to this day
but now he was asked if he was to speak
against
the pharmaceutical industry when he was
asked in a private conversation
with someone who brought this to
fruition to light he said look
if one of my anchors spoke out against
the pharmaceutical industry i'd have to
fire them why
because the majority of funding that
they get
comes from the pharmaceutical industry
drug companies
are offering huge money to scientists
people i call biostitutes they're
professors or they're
academic willing to author studies
50 60 percent and i believe that america
and i and one other country
maybe new zealand are the only ones that
promote the ads directly to the public
here now what does that tell us that
the people who are behind the scenes
running these big organizations they
have an agenda
they have if it's not an ideological
agenda
they're always going to express the
ideological views of their owners
a political agenda so a lot of times
these
mass media propaganda machines are used
in the games that people play
we don't want to fall in these traps so
we want to verify and now how the best
thing they say
is man just turn it off if you're not a
critical thinker
go on your business if you want to stay
healthy sane mind
healthy and thought and heart you want
to save your health
most of the time is the best to avoid
the mainstream media is to avoid it all
together
but if you're someone like for instance
myself people who are out there and
you're trying
to bring the truth to people sometimes
you have to get you have to be well
informed
so unless you have a better idea one
idea is
maybe if you take some information from
the fox news you take some from cnn
you go outside the box and you look at
independent
organizations what they have to say and
at the same time the most important
thing is
that you're making the dua to the
creator of the hemison earth
o allah god almighty allah help me to
see truth as truth
and help me to be able to follow it and
help me to see falsehood and falsehood
and be able to avoid it but don't get
overly invested
in any anchor and any news organization
we know there's always been some new
terrorists on the block
how are they able to convince the whole
world that muslims are terrorists look
look look at the propaganda fear machine
and we know it why
because we're well informed in our deen
in islam we know what islam promotes
love peace mercy justice for all the
pure monotheism
we know that because we're well well
informed in our deen
or we're supposed to be so even the
person with a little bit of knowledge of
islam he knows
this is false this is fake news right
away we spot it
when they were able to convince the
whole world
that now a certain country had weapons
of mass destruction
and they went in and pillaged and
plundered and the whole
uh everybody was on board
but we knew this was a lie and then
later it came out
and it was exposed that it was one of
the greatest lies but
what happened later i mean how many
millions and millions of
innocent lives were lost that's the lie
machine the propaganda machine
if you're wondering what you just saw
that was a montage spliced together by
timothy burke from deadspin
it's a mashup of dozens of anchors on
different stations
reciting the same eerie script
ironically
about the dangers of fake news because
this also means
a small number of ceos and billionaires
hold
big sway over how the american public
thinks
and then they were able to convince
people on so many other things
that are out there the whole thing with
the palestinians
one of the most oppressed people now and
look at the lie machine there
still and if you go up against it all
your conspiracy theorists et cetera et
cetera
but you know because you're well
informed you know what's going on
should we keep going down the list of
how many things out there
that are out there that are perpetuated
if you're informed in it you see oh if
the light bulb goes on
because i've been informed i was
critical thinking and i can see past the
lies
but what about the other things now the
whole climate and everything that's
being pushed
are we doing our critical thinking maybe
you can't change nothing
but you cannot submit with your heart
and mind that's the least you can do and
you can hate it as the prophet sallam
said
the last and final mission sent to
mankind the least of it if you cannot
change it speak out against it
if you cannot do anything with your
hands to change it
you can hate it and detest it in your
heart so we see a lot of evil
gains being played with these political
parties we see a lot of
agendas now that are being pushed people
piggybacking
off the current climate we see people
being
further driven away from the masjids we
see people further
we worked so hard to give the da'wah to
call people
to the dean and now we see with the
current climate
people being divided not just muslims
being
divided humanity being divided but we
look forward alhamdulillah they part and
plan allah
is the best of planners because allah
plans the best of plans
so imagine if we didn't have this deen
if we didn't have allah
so we know there's a greater good that
will come but at the same time while all
this is going on
don't be sheep do your critical thinking
investigate like allah tells us to
investigate so we can be better
well informed don't be overly
invested in a particular mainstream news
organization
and don't live in fear don't live in
fear
you see
look at this ayah beautiful we tie our
camo of course
we take our precautions but as allah god
almighty tells us
that no harm can come to us
except what is decreed by the qatar of
allah
so don't live don't suppress your immune
system by living in fear in paranoia
and we see it happening you're so scared
and now they have a new terrorist on the
block
and you know his name so let's be oh
muslims allah doesn't want us to be
sheep
allah doesn't want us to be falling in
these traps of shaytan
and remember shaitaan the one who is not
an ally with allah is
ally with shaytan and you have many of
these people out there
who are pushing the buttons
and shaytan's at the top with them
guiding them which ways to go
don't be ignorant to these things
don't be naive and have your head in the
sand so this is my
small advice that i wanted to share with
you guys
if you have some better ways of being a
better critical thinker
share that with us share that in the
comments but stay awake
stay connected to allah ask allah
constantly to guide you to guide us
and make sure
that you think outside the box so you
have a more holistic approach
with everything that you do and we're a
middle nation
and stay on that middle peace be with
you assalamu alaikum